This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。百分之二。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数只占这个比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在当今这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索数字“2”也就是英文的TWO点percent。欢迎收听《Look Back at It》播客。从1979年开始，对我来说那是意义重大的一年。1984年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，回顾当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方都可能不够安全，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一层铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。“埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这里我们探讨20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to discuss something a little bit different. we're going to talk about what it means to be an attractive person, our fascination, our obsession with beauty, and why it is that we find some people more good looking than others, alongside the impact of phenomena like pretty privilege and the impact of beauty standards. This is an episode that I've wanted to do for a while, because I think a lot of us in our 20s, myself included, spend a lot of time thinking, worrying, judging ourselves based on whether or not we match up with
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析20多岁的心理学。今天，我们要讨论一些稍微不同的事情。我们要谈谈成为一个有吸引力的人意味着什么，我们对美的迷恋、痴迷，以及为什么我们觉得有些人比其他人更好看，同时还有“美貌特权”等现象的影响以及审美标准的影响。这是一期我一直想做的节目，因为我认为我们很多20多岁的人，包括我自己，都花了大量时间去思考、担忧、评判自己，依据是我们是否符合
a version of what is conventionally beautiful. It's something that we cannot deny caring about. We are constantly aware, I guess, of some invisible standard of attractiveness, of beauty, of looks, of features that are going to make us more socially appealing. And I think at times we are too aware to the point that it really influences our behavior. We change certain things about ourselves, the clothes we wear, the hairstyles that we have, our makeup, even our weight, our physical form, our facial features through things like cosmetic surgery as a way to not only feel more confident, but I also think to conform to a lot of societal expectations and norms around beauty. I think at times that this comes at a really huge personal consequence,
传统意义上的美。这是我们无法否认自己会在乎的事情。我想，我们时刻都在意识到某种对吸引力、美貌、外表、特征的无形标准，这些特征会让我们在社交上更具吸引力。而且我认为有时我们的这种意识到了一种程度，以至于它真正影响了我们的行为。我们改变了关于自己的某些事情，我们穿的衣服，我们的发型，我们的妆容，甚至是我们的体重、我们的体型、我们的面部特征，通过诸如整容手术之类的事情，不仅是为了让自己感觉更自信，而且我也认为是为了顺应许多围绕美的社会期望和规范。我认为有时这会带来非常巨大的个人代价，
where we are unable to see our worth beyond our physical appearance. We begin to see our bodies in very unrealistic ways or kind of refuse to feel good about ourselves unless we look a certain way on the day. And unless we conform to what the beauty standard is of the day or the month or the year. You know, are we trying to look like a Kardashian today or like Bella Hadid? Or some other model or famous image of what beauty is and should be. and I think that can be harmful.
让我们无法看到自己除了外表之外的价值。我们开始以非常不现实的方式看待自己的身体，或者除非我们在当天的外表看起来符合某种特定要求，否则就拒绝自我感觉良好。除非我们符合当代、当月或当年的审美标准。你知道，我们今天是在努力看起来像卡戴珊还是贝拉·哈迪德？或者其他某个模特或大众心中美应该有的名流形象。而且我认为这可能是有害的。
And it's obviously on our minds a lot. A study published in Australia, literally just a few months ago, suggested that nearly a third of women in their 20s have considered or are considering cosmetic surgery. I won't lie. I'm in that boat. I have spoken to my friends about baby Botox or filler
这显然经常占据我们的脑海。澳大利亚刚刚在几个月前发表的一项研究表明，近三分之一的20多岁女性已经考虑过或正在考虑整容手术。我不撒谎。我也在这个行列中。过去这一年，我和朋友们讨论婴儿肉毒杆菌、填充物
or chin reduction surgery so much this past year more than I ever thought that I would. And I used to feel really ashamed that I didn't love my body enough to keep it the way that it was. But I've realized and I've come to recognize that our obsession with attractiveness is also highly universal. And as psychology will show us, very instinctual to our human nature. Part of human nature is a desire to be attractive because attractiveness symbolizes
或者下巴缩窄手术的次数，比我以往想象的都要多。我曾经为自己没有足够爱自己的身体、没能让它保持原样而感到非常羞愧。但我已经意识到并开始认识到，我们对吸引力的痴迷在很大程度上也是普遍存在的。正如心理学将向我们展示的那样，这是我们人性中非常本能的一部分。人性的一部分就是渴望具有吸引力，因为吸引力象征着
so much more than just surface value looks. attractiveness has this unspoken and implied association with things like status and wealth, but also of course health, reproductive value, the quote unquote quality of our genetics. These are all characteristics that we are hardwired to value because they are associated with better life outcomes and a higher kind of place in the social hierarchy. If you want to think about it in a very rudimentary way, psychologists who kind of examine the social and the psychological impacts of beauty, they often explain why we find certain things attractive, why we are concerned with our looks based on our ability to reproduce, based on what they call our mating instinct. So some of these theories are of course a little bit outdated in the modern world, but it's been suggested that one of our primary drives as humans
远不止表面的外表。吸引力和地位、财富等事物有着这种心照不宣且隐含的关联，当然也包括健康、生殖价值、所谓基因的“质量”。这些都是我们生来就倾向于珍视的特征，因为它们与更好的生活结果以及在社会等级中更高的地位息息相关。如果你想用一种非常初级的方式来思考这个问题，那些研究美的社会和心理影响的心理学家，他们经常根据我们的繁殖能力、根据他们所谓的“交配本能”，来解释为什么我们发现某些事物具有吸引力，为什么我们关心自己的外表。因此，其中一些理论在现代世界中当然有点过时了，但有人提出，作为人类，我们的首要驱动力之一
is to basically just have children and to have the healthiest offspring possible so that they are more likely to survive and carry on our genetics. Part of having healthy children comes down to picking a mate whose own DNA background genetics is going to best match ours and create the kind of children, offspring, kids that are going to have a fighting chance. This is very, very evolutionary. Obviously, nowadays, we have so many different medical innovations and techniques and methods that it doesn't really matter if, you know, your child has certain little quirks about them
基本上就是生孩子，并孕育出尽可能健康的后代，这样他们就更有可能生存下来并将我们的基因延续下去。拥有健康孩子的其中一部分归结为选择一个伴侣，其自身的DNA背景基因将与我们的基因最完美地匹配，并孕育出那种有一战之力的儿童、后代、孩子。这非常非常具有进化意义。显然，如今我们有如此之多的不同医疗创新、技术和方法，以至于你的孩子身上有一些这样那样的小怪癖，其实并没有太大关系。
or certain things where they're not as healthy as they should be. like they're still going to survive potentially to old age. But back in the day when we didn't have medical care because we were like roaming the jungle, roaming the Sahara, picking the right partner who was going to give your kids the best chance of survival was really important. Obviously when we are making that decision, we cannot peer into someone's genetic blueprint and find out if they are healthy or not. We can't peer into their DNA and find out what kind of medical,
或者某些地方不够健康。比如他们可能依然能存活到老年。但在过去，当我们没有医疗保健的时候，因为我们在丛林中游荡，在撒哈拉沙漠中游荡，选择正确的伴侣来给你的孩子提供最好的生存机会是非常重要的。显然，当我们做出这个决定时，我们无法窥视某人的基因蓝图来查明他们是否健康。我们无法窥视他们的 DNA 来找出他们有什么样的医疗、
preconditions or predispositions they have, but we can look at their physical traits and kind of identify whether or not, A, these characteristics are indicative of better health, and B, would that make for healthier offspring who are more likely to survive? So the things that we typically see is beautiful, things like youthfulness, good skin, nice hair, tall, muscular, large eyes, they are actually all indicative of someone's almost capacity to survive and also of their health. That is why we find certain things attractive, not because they are more attractive in a really arbitrary sense, but because of how they help with our sense of security, our sense of survival, our ability to pass on our genetics. So the one I always think of is like why we find tall men more attractive. Like there
前提条件或先天倾向，但我们可以观察他们的身体特征，并借此识别：A，这些特征是否表明他们拥有更好的健康状况；B，这是否能造就更健康的后代，从而更有可能生存下来。因此，我们通常认为美丽的事物——比如年轻、好皮肤、漂亮的头发、高大、肌肉发达、大眼睛——实际上都表明了一个人几乎具有生存能力以及他们的健康状况。这就是为什么我们觉得某些事物具有吸引力，不是因为它们在某种非常随意的意义上更具吸引力，而是因为它们如何帮助我们获得安全感、生存感、以及我们传递基因的能力。所以我总是想到的一点是，为什么我们觉得高个子男人更有吸引力。比如，
really isn't any reason other than a very biological, evolutionary reason, to have a preference for taller men if that is your preference. But previously, prehistoricly, someone who was taller may have been more athletic, may have been stronger, may have been more able to reach the fruit high up on the tree. Those were all big perks, big kind of pros when it come to producing healthy surviving children. Those factors are now, as I said before, not as important, but they are still part of our genetic blueprint. They are still part of our DNA. And it's interesting because the standard of what we find attractive is actually pretty consistent across populations, ages, genders, ethnicity, with only a few deviations, suggesting that really deep down
除了一个非常生物学的、进化的原因之外，如果你对高个子男人有偏好，真的没有别的理由了。但在史前时期，长得更高的人可能更具运动能力、可能更强壮、可能更有能力够到树上高处的果实。当涉及到产生健康的、能够生存的后代时，这些都是很大的优势、很大的优点。正如我之前所说，这些因素现在已经没有那么重要了，但它们仍然是我们基因蓝图的一部分。它们仍然是我们DNA的一部分。有趣的是，我们觉得有吸引力的标准实际上在不同人群、年龄、性别、种族之间相当一致，只有极少数的偏差，这表明在内心深处
there is this like kind of profile or image of the perfect person. So in one meta-analysis, they looked at over 900 studies on this and they found that if they gave people a big group of different individuals from different backgrounds, different ages, different genders, all of those things, most people in these large groups would come to an agreement on who was the most attractive amongst this group, even if they themselves had different backgrounds. This strongly suggests that judgments of physical attractiveness are really hardwired into human genetics. They're also likely to be fixed at a really early stage in kind of our upbringing and
确实存在着这样一种完美之人的轮廓或形象。因此在一项元分析中，他们研究了对此进行的900多项研究，发现如果他们给人们一大群来自不同背景、不同年龄、不同性别等各种各样的个体，这个大群中的大多数人都会对这群人中谁最有吸引力达成一致，即使他们自己有着不同的背景。这强烈表明，对身体吸引力的判断确实深深植根于人类基因之中。它们也很可能在我们成长和
development. We actually devote entire portions of our brain to evaluating characteristics of attractiveness. They did studies on six-month-old infants, and what they found was that these kids, although they're only six months out of the room, they can't even speak yet, they look longer at the faces of adults who we would call objectively attractive. And they spend less time looking at faces of those who we would judge as not attractive. Because as we've concluded, it's not just about beauty, the social idea of beauty. It's about something very primal, an animal in our brain that has been programmed to pay attention to looks. The brain is actually such a good detector of beauty that it can
发展的非常早期阶段就被固定下来了。事实上，我们将大脑的整个部分用于评估吸引力的特征。他们对六个月大的婴儿进行了研究，发现这些孩子虽然才出生六个月，甚至还不会说话，但他们会更长时间地看着那些我们称之为客观上有吸引力的成人的脸。而他们花在那些我们判定为没有吸引力的面孔上的时间则更少。因为正如我们所总结的，这不仅仅关于美，关于审美的社会观念。这是关于某种非常原始的东西，我们大脑中的动物性已被编程为关注外表。大脑实际上是一个非常优秀的审美探测器，它甚至可以在
actually judge the appeal of a face before we are even aware that you've seen it. So when participants in a recent study were presented with an attractive and an unattractive face, they had only 13 milliseconds to look at them both. And from that, just very, very brief vision, they were able to judge which of these faces the average person would call more attractive. So they're not even consciously aware of the stimuli, and yet we are almost on an unconscious level able to pick up the certain features that make a person healthier, make a person more attractive, make a person more desirable when it comes to mating. So what are the sum of the features that we're kind of, we universally accept as being attractive
我们甚至还没意识到自己看过它之前，就对一张脸的吸引力做出判断。因此，当最近一项研究中的参与者面对一张有吸引力和一张没有吸引力的面孔时，他们只有13毫秒的时间来观察这两张面孔。从这个非常非常短暂的视觉中，他们能够判断出平均水平的人会觉得这两张面孔中的哪一张更有吸引力。因此，他们甚至没有有意识地察觉到这些刺激，然而我们在潜意识层面上几乎能够挑出那些让一个人更健康、让一个人更有吸引力、让一个人在交配时更具渴望度的特定特征。那么，我们普遍接受并正在寻找的有吸引力的特征有哪些呢？
that we're looking out for? key elements that go into our appraisal of beauty on a very, very rudimentary primal level, are age and health as well as facial symmetry, body proportions, facial colour and texture, mainly to do with things like skin. Youth is obviously a major component when it comes to attractiveness. Older faces are judged as less attractive, less energetic, once again because of reproductive viability. So we do have this obsession with wanting to look younger
在非常、非常初级的原始水平上，构成我们对美的评价的关键要素是年龄和健康，以及面部对称性、身体比例、面部颜色和质地，这主要与皮肤之类的事物有关。说到吸引力，年轻显然是一个主要组成部分。年纪稍大的面孔被认为吸引力较低、活力较低，这同样是因为生殖能力。因此，我们确实对想要显得年轻有一种执念
because we understand that looking younger means that we are more attractive to the average person because it indicates that our time to have children has not yet come to an end. This really explains like our obsession with Botox and youthful beauty routines and retinol and whatever else there is that is meant to keep us looking younger for as long as possible.
因为我们明白，看起来更年轻意味着对普通人更有吸引力，因为这表明我们生孩子的时期还没有结束。这真正解释了我们对肉毒杆菌、年轻化美容日常、视黄醇以及其他旨在让我们尽可能长时间保持年轻外观的事物的痴迷。
Facial and body symmetry are also a big thing that we instinctually look for. And I found this really interesting when I discovered this, because the reason why we like symmetrical faces is really fascinating. There are really small variables that can make it so that we do not have a symmetrical face. You could have a slightly wider jaw on one side or one of your eyes could be like a tiny fraction lower than the other one. one of your cheekbones might stick out just a wee bit more, a little dimple on one cheek. These are just small quirks that we may love in someone else and that we might find attractive. But what this science and the psychology is suggesting is that when we look at someone who has a symmetrical face versus an asymmetrical face,
面部和身体对称也是我们本能寻找的一个大方向。当我发现这一点时，我发现这真的很有趣，因为我们喜欢对称面孔的原因真的很吸引人。有一些非常小的变量会导致我们的脸不对称。你可能一侧的下巴稍微宽一点，或者你的眼睛之一可能比另一个稍微低那么微小的一点。你的一个颧骨可能会稍微突出一点点，或者一个脸颊上有一个小酒窝。这些只是我们在别人身上可能会喜爱并觉得有吸引力的小怪癖。但这门科学和心理学所表明的是，当我们看着一个拥有对称面孔的人与一个不对称面孔的人时，
our preference is always going to be for symmetry. Firstly, symmetry is good, is valued because it's easier to interpret the emotions of those who have this kind of bilateral symmetry. So basically it means that if you have someone whose face is kind of exactly the same on either side, you know exactly how emotions are going to be displayed compared to someone who might have small little differences that might warp how you would traditionally or are used to seeing emotions. It's also the fact that asymmetry, having a little bit of a difference, is kind of a sign of congenital or developmental defects. Not so much anymore, but in the past. They might be a sign of malnutrition or infection or indicative of a deeper genetic mutation. You know, those minor variations, like having a dimple, having like a slightly higher cheekbone, that is not going to have any functional consequences. They do not have a dramatic impact on our lives. But what we are
我们的偏好永远是追求对称。首先，对称是好的、是有价值的，因为更容易解读那些具有这种双侧对称性的人的情绪。所以基本上这意味着，如果你的脸在两侧几乎完全相同，你确切地知道情绪将如何表达，相比之下，某些人可能会有细微的差异，从而扭曲你传统上或习惯看到的那些情绪。这也是因为不对称——有一点差异——是一种先天或发育缺陷的迹象。现在这种现象虽然不多了，但在过去是这样的。它们可能是营养不良或感染的迹象，或者是更深层基因突变的标志。你知道，那些微小的变异，比如有一个酒窝，有一个稍微高一点的颧骨，并不会带来任何功能上的后果。它们对我们的生活没有戏剧性的影响。但我们
finding again and again is that symmetry is much more attractive. It is more highly rated as being associated with dominance and health and sexiness. Once again, because it comes back to the genetic desirability of a mate. Beauty perceptions obviously differ for men and women, particularly when we're talking about cisgender heteronormative men and women. And that's really where most of the research is being done because I don't know about the rest of the scientific community, but the psychology community is a little bit behind in recognizing kind of the diversity of genders and sex. But from what they've shown, when we look at things like facial hair, for example, that is indicative of higher testosterone levels. It's also associated with greater fertility and strength. So women are more
一次又一次发现的是，对称要吸引人得多。它被高度评价为与统治力、健康和性感相关。再次说明，因为这归结为伴侣的基因合意性。对男性和女性而言，审美的感知显然有所不同，特别是当我们谈论顺性别异性恋男性和女性时。这确实是大部分研究所在的地方，因为我不知道其他科学界的情况，但心理学界在认识到性别和性取向的多样性方面稍微落后了一点。但从他们所展示的情况来看，当我们看面部毛发之类的东西时，例如，这表明更高的睾酮水平。它还与更高的生育能力和力量有关。所以女性更有
likely to prefer men who have those features or who have a muscular build or high cheekbones, not just because they're more sexually attractive, but because they might be a better long-term mate. And then when it comes to women and male preferences for women, often it's things like having large hips, having large breasts, having nice skin, having long hair because it indicates that you are going to be able to give birth to healthy. children and also that you have like you're getting good nutrition that you are healthy that you are taking care of yourselves these are just some of the features that we're looking for that a lot of people find attractive right and once again it's mainly linked to reproductive capacity viability
可能偏爱那些具有这些特征，或者拥有肌肉线条或高颧骨的男性，不仅因为他们在性方面更有吸引力，还因为他们可能是更好的长期伴侣。而说到女性以及男性对女性的偏好，通常是诸如拥有大臀部、大胸部、好皮肤、长头发等特征，因为这表明你将能够生下健康的儿童，并且还表明你获得了良好的营养、你是健康的、你正在照顾好自己。这些只是我们在寻找的、许多人觉得有吸引力的部分特征，对吧？而且再次强调，这主要与生殖能力、生存力息息相关。
and i feel like we spend a lot of time here discussing that fact what we find attractive and why but i also want to investigate what are the consequences of of meeting that profile of attractiveness or not. You know, it's not all about mating and having kids. I think we are a bit more evolved nowadays to realize that not everyone wants to have children. But based on our conclusions, beauty standards are only important
我觉得我们在这里花了很多时间讨论这个事实：我们觉得什么有吸引力以及为什么。但我也想探究一下，符合或不符合那种吸引力形象的后果是什么。你知道，这并不完全关乎交配和生孩子。我认为现在我们在进化上更加成熟了，意识到并非每个人都想生孩子。但根据我们的结论，审美标准之所以重要，
because of how they relate to reproducing. If that's the case, you have this whole group of people who don't want kids, kids and yet they still really care about their looks. So we're kind of missing a part of the equation here. I think that is that we as a society implicitly understand and acknowledge that how we look, our beauty levels, our attractiveness levels, they are important for our social relationships and for how we are treated. A lot of that comes down to the concept of pretty privilege. Our acknowledgement that people who are perceived as more beautiful or as meeting beauty
仅仅是因为它们与生育有关。如果是这样的话，你就有一大群人根本不想要孩子，然而他们仍然非常在意自己的外表。所以我们在这里漏掉了方程的一部分。我认为那就是我们作为一个社会，含蓄地理解并承认我们的外表、我们的美貌水平、我们的吸引力水平，对我们的社会关系以及我们受到的待遇非常重要。这很大程度上归结为“美貌特权”的概念。我们承认，那些被认为更美丽或符合美貌
norms are going to get better or preferential treatment. So there was a study conducted back in 2019 published in the Behavioral Science Journal. It found that throughout the world, attractive people show greater acquisition of resources and better treatment than others. and it's often those people that we celebrate and promote and see as beautiful, they follow a very similar formula. They are thin, they are white, they are young, they are cisgendered, they are tall, they have good skin, they have long hair. Not necessarily the everyday person and definitely not the only version of beauty. And you know what, let's point out the obvious before going any further, that is super unfair. It's unfair, it is an unfair world to live in, especially when the way that you look
标准的人将获得更好或优先的待遇。因此，2019年发表在《行为科学杂志》上的一项研究表明。研究发现，在世界各地，有吸引力的人比其他人表现出更多的资源获取和更好的待遇。而且往往是那些我们庆祝、推广并视为美丽的群体，他们遵循着非常相似的公式。他们很瘦，是白人，很年轻，是顺性别者，很高，皮肤很好，头发很长。这不一定是一般人，也绝对不是唯一的审美版本。你知道吗，在继续之前让我们指出显而易见的一点，这超级不公平。这很不公平，生活在一个不公平的世界里，尤其是当你长相如何
really has nothing to do with how good of a person you are. It is genetic luck. It has nothing to do with your value as a person, how kind you are, how intelligent you are, how caring you are, and yet we cannot implicitly escape this privilege that exists all around us, whereby if you happen to match this profile of what is attractiveness, life just might be a little bit easier for you. So they've done studies on this and they've found that people who are appraised as objectively beautiful, they are paid more, they get considered for more jobs, they are seen as nicer, as more intelligent, more trustworthy. They even did this one quite recently and it was around employment and they found that if you are someone who is good looking, you make about 12% more than people who are
其实和你是一个多好的人毫无关系。这是基因上的运气。它与你作为人的价值、你的善良程度、你的聪明程度、你的关心程度毫无关系，然而我们却无法隐含地逃避这种存在于我们周围的特权：如果你碰巧符合这种有吸引力的轮廓，你的生活可能会稍微轻松一点。因此，他们对此进行了研究，发现那些被评估为客观上美丽的人，薪水更高，能获得更多的工作机会，被认为更友善、更聪明、更值得信赖。他们甚至在最近做过这样一项研究，是关于就业的，他们发现如果你是一个长相好看的人，你的收入比那些被认为
deemed less appealing. It's the same thing with real estate brokers. If you're more attractive as someone who works in real estate, you make a lot more money. Psychologists call it the beauty premium. Essentially, it is the income gap between attractive and unattractive people. And one study has suggested, one group of researchers suggested that this beauty premium, this income gap is comparable to the gap between genders or ethnicities. We have some idea of why that is, but just because we understand that it comes from this weird genetic blueprint preferences, offspring, whatever, it doesn't necessarily make us feel good. It doesn't make us feel better to understand that even though it's biology and it doesn't have, you know, much to do with us,
没那么吸引人的人高出大约12%。房地产经纪人也是如此。如果你是一个从事房地产工作且更有吸引力的人，你会赚更多的钱。心理学家称之为“美貌溢价”。本质上，它是具吸引力的人和不具吸引力的人之间的收入差距。一项研究表明，一组研究人员提出，这种美貌溢价、这种收入差距与性别或种族之间的差距相当。我们对此有一些概念，但仅仅因为我们理解它来自这种奇怪的基因蓝图偏好、后代等等，并不一定让我们感觉良好。明白尽管这是生物学，而且与我们没有太大关系，
it's not in our control. It's still pretty unfair. It's also really interesting. to me because although we do have some really universal ideas of beauty, the standards around us are constantly shifting and impossible to meet. One week we need to look stick thin, the next week we're expected to look lean and muscular. After that, we're meant to have really big boobs and big butts. That is because beauty standards are social norms, meaning that they are socially constructed. A social construct is not only very likely to shift and change quite quickly, often with no reason, but it actually has no real meaning beyond the group in which it is enforced. Social constructs only have power if the group chooses to enforce them. They are literally
它不在我们的控制范围内，但这并不能让我们感觉更好。这仍然很不公平。这也让我感到很有趣。尽管我们对美有一些非常普遍的观念，但我们周围的标准却在不断变化且根本无法达到。一个星期我们需要骨感苗条，下一个星期我们又被期望看起来精瘦且肌肉分明。在这之后，我们又得拥有非常大的胸部和大的臀部。那是因为审美标准是社会规范，这意味着它们是社会建构的。社会建构不仅很可能会相当快地转变和改变，而且通常毫无理由，除了实施它的群体之外，它实际上没有任何真正的意义。只有当群体选择执行它们时，社会建构才具有权力。它们简直
not real, but they do feel real because they are enforced in very implicit ways for example, limited clothing sizes at stores, limited shades of makeup, identical models in every advertisement. But the fact that they are a social construct means that they can be changed almost overnight or dramatically because they are derived from really the minds of millions of people, but then backed up by and reflected by industries who make money from your insecurity, who make money from selling us a new standard, a new product, a new version of how you should be. How is it that we are meant to keep up with those changing beauty standards that make it so
并非真实，但它们确实让人感觉真实，因为它们是以非常含蓄的方式强加给我们的，例如，商店里有限的服装尺码、有限的粉底色号、每个广告中长相相同的模特。但它们是一个社会建构这一事实意味着它们几乎可以一夜之间或剧烈地改变，因为它们源自数百万人的思想，然后得到那些靠你的不安全感赚钱的行业的支持和反映，靠向我们出售新标准、新产品、关于你应该如何生活的新版本的行业来支撑。我们到底该如何跟上这些不断变化的审美标准？它们使得
your looks have to be the center of your universe, kind of a constant source of attention? I think that that is really, really impossible, especially when we understand that we will be validated by society if we are conventionally attractive. All of us want to be accepted, of us want preferential treatment. All of us want to be treated well. And what beauty standards and pretty privilege is really telling us is that you can have that life. This can all be unlocked for you if you just conform to how we would like you to look. That has a lot of consequences for our mental health, our social health, our emotional health. So how do we kind of break free from these expectations and this pressure and just be happy with who we are beyond our physical appearance? We're going to
你的外表不得不成为你世界的中心，成为源源不断的关注焦点？我认为这真的非常非常不可能，尤其是当我们明白如果我们符合传统审美，就会得到社会的认可。我们所有人都希望被接纳，我们所有人都希望得到优先对待。我们所有人都希望被善待。审美标准和美貌特权真正告诉我们的是，你可以拥有那种生活。只要你顺从我们希望你看起来的样子，这一切都可以为你解锁。这对我们的心理健康、社会健康、情感健康有很多负面影响。那么我们如何才能摆脱这些期望和压力，超越外表，对自我感到满意呢？我们将
going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
在短暂的休息后讨论所有这些以及更多内容。《2%》。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数只占这个比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在当今这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以摆脱主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。请注意，2%中的“percent”拼写是P-E-R-S-E-N-T。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击莉莉·金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉莉·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，回顾当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的访谈，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，1984年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们会看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同信任层面的东西。我希望你能够真正地去做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L.S. Correct? I doctored the test once.
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们一起进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。“埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。“我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。”阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The problem with beauty standards and the pretty privilege that comes along with it is twofold.
这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，突发新闻。马里科帕县传来消息，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。审美标准以及随之而来的美貌特权的问题在于两点。
Firstly, it teaches us that our value is entirely derived from our physical appearance. rather than the contents of our character and our soul and our personality. Secondly, it says and it shows us and it ingrains in us that we need to change in order to be accepted. That leads to a lot of very deeply rooted dissatisfaction with our bodies, with how we look, and this misconception that our lives would be better if we just looked a certain way or fixed something about ourselves. I see this all the time in my own behavior, in the behavior of those around me, and it's so upsetting to think how many of us believe that if we just lost some weight, we'd be able to find love, or if we fixed our skin, we would be liked more by people that we work with or people around us
首先，它教导我们，我们的价值完全源于我们的外表，而不是我们的品格、灵魂和个性的内涵。其次，它告诉我们、向我们展示并根深蒂固地让我们认为，我们需要改变才能被接纳。这导致了对我们的身体、对外表的极其根深蒂固的不满，以及这种误解：如果我们只是长成某种特定样子或者修复了身上的某个部位，我们的生活就会变得更好。我在我自己的行为中、在我周围人的行为中一直看到这一点，想到我们中有多少人认为只要减掉一些体重就能找到真爱，或者只要修护好皮肤就能更受同事、周围人或
or people on the street. If we just touched something up there, altered something here, we would be more successful. It is never-ending, because I think when you start believing this myth, sold to you by a society obsessed with beauty that changing your appearance will somehow change the quality of your life, you will always find something else to be unhappy about or to not like about yourself. It's why we now see these terms for people who are addicted to plastic surgery or body modifications. It's why we're seeing rising numbers of body dysmorphic disorders and eating disorders. Harvard University even published a paper on this recently
街上行人的喜爱，这让我感到非常沮丧。如果我们只是在那里修饰一下，在这里改变一下，我们就会更成功。这是没完没了的，因为我认为当你开始相信这个由沉迷于外表的社会向你兜售的神话——即改变外表会以某种方式改变生活质量——你总会找到其他不开心或不喜欢自己的地方。这就是为什么我们现在看到那些对整容手术或身体改造上瘾的人有了这些新词。这就是为什么我们看到身体变形障碍和进食障碍的数量不断上升。哈佛大学最近甚至就此发表了一篇论文
suggesting that when we see our value as being determined by beauty, this translates into self-objectification. And that negatively impacts the treatment we feel we deserve, especially for women, where when we begin to see ourselves as an object that can be admired, that looks beautiful, we kind of start to minimize these other aspects of our identity and ourselves that are more important, self-objectification is associated with decreased political activism, less assertiveness, poorer workplace performance, because when we conform to an idea that beauty is our only value in the world that we need to look a certain way, what that basically means is that your accompanying idea of personhood and personality is restricted. It becomes less multi-dimensional. You don't need to
表明，当我们认为自己的价值由美貌决定时，这就会转化为自我客体化。这会对我们觉得自己应得的待遇产生负面影响，特别是对女性而言，当我们开始将自己视为一个可以被欣赏、看起来很漂亮的物品时，我们就会开始淡化身份和自我中那些更重要的其他方面。自我客体化与政治激进主义减少、自信心下降、工作场所表现变差有关，因为当我们顺从“美是我们在世界上唯一的价值，我们需要看起来像某种特定样子”这一观念时，这基本上意味着你对个性和人格的伴随观念受到了限制。它变得不再那么多维度。你不需要
be intelligent. You don't need to be creative or assertive. You are merely something that is nice to look at, which we know is entirely incorrect. We are incredibly nuanced, well-rounded, deep individuals. But when we form an obsession with our looks and needing to fit a certain standard in order to be accepted, that really just becomes the highlight. It becomes the only thing we can focus on. So I want to offer a few reminders here for those moments when you're buying into the beauty standards, the pretty privilege of the world. Number one, there might be one standard of beauty that is most common, but that doesn't mean that beauty is a singularly defined thing. As the saying always goes, beauty is in the high of the beholder and the things that we might
聪明。你不需要有创造力或自信。你仅仅是一个长相好看的东西，我们知道这完全是不正确的。我们是极其细腻、全面、深刻的个体。但当我们对自己的外表产生执念，并且需要符合某种标准才能被接受时，那真的就成了重中之重。它成了我们唯一能关注的事情。所以我想在这里为那些正在接受世俗审美标准、美貌特权的时刻提供一些提醒。第一，可能确实存在一种最常见的审美标准，但这并不像意味着美是一个单一定义的事物。正如那句老话所说，情人眼里出西施，我们可能
see as flaws, others might see as kind of really beautiful parts of our tapestry as a human or a really attractive quirk. I think sometimes with phrases like that, we think that they've just been developed to make us feel better. But I'm always surprised by how much truth there are in these like everyday metaphors or idioms. So research is actually suggested that beauty is in fact in the high of the beholder. There is a preference for certain physical traits, but also it is our individual life experiences that leads us to find certain people more attractive than others, not just our genetics, not just our DNA. It's why your best friend might be like absolutely smitten with someone and you think they're like a solid three.
视为缺点的事物，其他人可能会将其视为我们人类生活画卷中非常美丽的部分，或者是非常有吸引力的小怪癖。我认为有时对于这样的短语，我们会认为它们只是为了让我们感觉更好而创造出来的。但我总是对这些日常隐喻或成语中蕴含了多少真理感到惊讶。因此，研究实际上表明，美确实存在于观者的眼中。人们对某些身体特征有偏好，但这也是我们个人的生活经历导致我们发现某些人比其他人更有吸引力，而不仅仅是我们的基因，不仅仅是我们的DNA。这就是为什么你最好的朋友可能会对某人神魂颠倒，而你觉得对方普普通通。
It's why we have different types. It's why we find some celebrities unattractive. Because life experiences are equally important here. It is about environment. It's about how much we value things like uniqueness, who our friends are dating, who we have dated in the past, what our culture is promoting as attractive, even what our parents look like. And that is a whole other chapter of psychology that I don't think we have time to get into. But essentially, some people theorize that we actually prefer partners who resemble our parents. And that is super weird. Some people say it's true. A lot more people say it's false and a little bit delusional. But I think it's evidence to show that it's not all about biology in these moments. It also is about how we have been
这就是为什么我们有不同的类型。这也是为什么我们会觉得某些名人没有吸引力。因为生活经验在这里同样重要。这关乎环境。这关乎我们有多珍视独特性、我们的朋友在和谁约会、我们过去和谁约过会、我们的文化宣扬什么样的人具有吸引力，甚至关乎我们父母长什么样。那是心理学中完全不同的一个篇章，我觉得我们没有时间深入探讨。但本质上，有些人推测我们实际上更喜欢长得像父母的伴侣。这超级奇怪。有些人说这是真的。更多的人说这是假的，而且有点妄想。但我认为这证明了在这些时刻，并不完全由生物学决定。这还关乎我们是如何被
raised, how we have been conditioned to see beauty, and also the kind of deviations in that as well, such that even if you don't feel conventionally attractive, there is someone out there who's looking at you being like, I think that they are the most beautiful person in the world. You know, I used to have this, like, real deep hatred for this mole I had on my face. I used to Google, like, skin removal places, like, once a day, at least. And it's so interesting because my current boyfriend loves it. He's like, that is so cute. You can just never tell what someone is going to find beautiful about you that you might actually
抚养长大的，我们是如何被潜移默化地看待美的，以及其中的各种偏差，因此，即使你觉得自己并不符合传统意义上的美，也会有人看着你，觉得你是世界上最美丽的人。你知道，我以前对脸上的这颗痣有着非常深恶痛绝的恨意。我曾经每天至少用谷歌搜索一次皮肤去除机构。这太有趣了，因为我现在的男友却很喜欢它。他说这太可爱了。你永远无法预料别人会觉得你的哪个部分很美，而你实际上可能会
find really unattractive because, once again, you can choose to conform and try and fit into someone else's version of a perfect body and a perfect face and whatnot. But when you do that, you also reduce your individuality in the process. And I think that individuality is what people ultimately love the most about you. My second reminder, and I think it goes without saying, but your appearance really is the least important thing about you. Your body is going to change as you age as you go through certain life events, but what will hopefully not change is the contents of who you are and how authentic and true to yourself you really choose to be. I'm always reminded of this Roald Dahl quote. He did this book, children's book called The Twits, and in it he says,
觉得非常难看，因为再强调一次，你可以选择随波逐流，试图融入别人对完美身材、完美脸蛋等的审美。但当你这么做时，你也在这个过程中削弱了你的个性。我认为正是这种个性最终才是人们最爱你的一点。我的第二个提醒，我觉得不用多说，但你的外表确实是你身上最不重要的东西。随着年龄的增长和经历特定的人生事件，你的身材会发生变化，但希望不会改变的是你的内在本质，以及你真正选择的真实和忠于自我的程度。我总是想起罗尔德·达尔的这句名言。他写过一本名为《小鬼当家》（The Twits）的儿童书，里面他说过，
a person who has good thoughts cannot be ugly. You can be the most hideous person out there, but if you have good thoughts, if you are kind to other people, these will shine out of your face like sunbeams and you will always look lovely. I truly believe this. Kind people can never be unattractive because they have shifted beyond thinking about themselves only on the singular dimension of appearance and have a holistic view of their character, what they bring to the world, how they treat others, how they treat themselves that is so much more important. Additionally, something I like to remind myself when I start to kind of think too much about my looks and start picking at things, start Googling random surgeries in Turkey, is that some of the greatest,
一个内心充满美好想法的人绝不可能是丑陋的。你可以是外表最丑陋的人，但如果你有美好的想法，如果你对他人善良，这些就会像阳光一样从你的脸上散发出来，你就会永远看起来很可爱。我坚信这一点。善良的人永远不会没有吸引力，因为他们已经不再仅仅从外表单一维度来思考自己，而是对自己的品格、对世界的贡献、如何对待他人、如何对待自己有着更全面的看法，这要重要得多。此外，当我开始对自己的外表想太多、开始挑剔各种毛病、开始在土耳其谷歌搜索各种随机整形手术时，我喜欢提醒自己的一点是，世界上一些最伟大、
smartest, most valuable people in this world do not meet the profile of what is attractive. People like Einstein, Steve Jobs, Mother Teresa, I don't think they could have done what they'd done, if they spent all that time worrying about their physical appearance more than their vision for the future. And I think it goes to show that in a world that really wants to teach you and really wants to enforce this philosophy that your looks are really, really valuable and really important and should be a big focus. There are thousands, millions of people who aren't thinking about that and who are thinking about how they can actually contribute to the world in a really meaningful way. and if they decided that they would rather focus on beauty and attractiveness,
最聪明、最有价值的人并不符合吸引力的标准。像爱因斯坦、史蒂夫·乔布斯、特蕾莎修女，我认为如果他们把所有时间都花在担心自己的外表上，而不是他们对未来的愿景上，他们就不可能取得他们所成就的那些事。我想这也表明，在一个极力想要教导你、极力想要向你灌输这样一种哲学——即你的外表真的非常有价值、非常重要且应该成为重中之重——的世界里。有成千上万、数以百万计的人并没有去想这些，而是在思考他们如何能以真正有意义的方式为世界做贡献。如果他们决定把重点放在美丽和吸引力上，
we would miss out on a lot of amazing inventions, a lot of amazing changes in this world. Number three, my final reminder, we can say all that we want about beauty standards and what makes someone attractive from kind of an evolutionary biological standpoint. But time and time again, what trumps attractiveness is confidence, much like kindness, I think. Confidence has this ability to always make you the most attractive
我们就会错过许多惊人的发明，错过这个世界上许多惊人的改变。第三点，我的最后提醒，关于审美标准以及从某种进化生物学的角度来看是什么让人具有吸引力，我们可以说想说的话。但一次又一次，胜过吸引力的总是自信，我想这和善良很像。自信有这样一种能力，总能让你成为房间里最具吸引力的
person in the room. And there's a science behind this. When you believe in yourself, when you are self-assured, when you know who you are, that kind of radiates outwards. It makes you appear more attractive to others. And it's this energy that a lot of people often call the glow, right? this like magnetic golden aura. And in one study conducted by the Society for Personality and Social Psychology, they recruited a bunch of people and they had half of them fake confidence in these make-believe dating situations. And they found that these individuals who kind of faked it till they made it were rated higher in romantic attractiveness and just overall desirability again and again and again. Additionally, a lot of the things that we inherently kind of
人。这背后是有科学依据的。当你相信自己，当你充满自信，当你了解自己时，这种状态就会向外辐射。它会让你在别人眼里显得更有吸引力。这就是许多人常说的“光芒”，对吧？这种磁性的金色光环。在人格与社会心理学协会进行的一项研究中，他们招募了一群人，让他们中的一半人在这些虚构的约会情境中假装自信。他们发现，这些“先假装直到成功”的人在浪漫吸引力和整体吸引力方面一次又一次地得到了更高的评分。此外，我们在伴侣身上本能地、
genetically desire in a partner are really difficult to observe directly unless you actually take time to get to know someone. Things like intelligence, drive, social status, physical ability, personality, they are kind of things that we understand about ourselves, but other people don't understand about us. However, when you are confident, a lot of of people around you will assume that there is a reason to that confidence because you do have an actual sense of value. I think, I hope that makes sense, but I guess what it says is you don't have to, these people don't have to question whether you have value, whether you're worth knowing, whether you're worth dating, whether you're worth investing in, because you already know it. And so
基因般渴望的很多东西，其实很难直接观察到，除非你真正花时间去了解一个人。诸如智力、进取心、社会地位、身体能力、个性等特质，是我们对自己有所了解，但别人并不了解我们的方面。然而，当你自信时，你身边的很多人会认为这种自信是有原因的，因为你确实拥有真正的价值。我想，我希望这说得通，但我想这说明的是，这些人不必去质疑你是否有价值，你是否值得去了解，你是否值得去约会，你是否值得去投资，因为你已经知道了。所以
they're more likely to believe you if you believe in yourself. I think that just goes to show that beauty is obviously not just skin deep. It's so much more nuanced and psychological. and emotional and our preoccupation with it is also probably going to be causing us more harm than good whereby the more we become fixated on changing things the less confidence we have so the less attractive we kind of become when we reframe our perspective and take physical appearance off a pedestal we feel so much more free to not have to perform and we can worry about pretty privilege and beauty standards as much as we like, we can acknowledge that the world is really designed for a small group of people. But each day, you also get to make a choice about whether you want to spend
如果你相信自己，他们就更有可能相信你。我认为这恰恰说明了美显然不仅仅流于表面。它要微妙得多，也更具心理和情感色彩，我们对它的过度关注也可能会给我们带来弊大于利的后果：我们越是执着于改变事物，我们的自信就越少，因而我们的吸引力也就越少。当我们重新调整视角，不再把外表奉为圭臬，我们会感到更加自由，不必再去表演，我们可以随心所欲地去关注特权阶层的美和审美标准，我们可以承认这个世界确实是为一小群人设计的。但每天，你也可以做出选择，是想把
your time thinking about this and trying to conform and spending money to look a certain way, or whether there's something else that is going to be more valuable that you can do with that time. How many hours are you wasting, fixating on something that? really isn't a true marker of who you are. How many minutes do you spend thinking like, my makeup doesn't look great, it looks a bit cakey? No one is really noticing that. And if they're making a step judgment based on that small aspect of who you are, that is highly superficial and it has nothing to do with you. So it's kind of like a bit of a balancing act here. What are you giving up by spending time thinking about this and what could you gain by spending that time thinking about
时间花在思考这些问题、试图随波逐流以及花钱打扮成某种样子上，还是觉得有其他更有价值的事情可以用这些时间去做。你浪费了多少小时，纠结于那些其实并不是你真实标志的东西？你花了多少分钟想：“我的妆看起来不太好，有点卡粉”？根本没人注意到这一点。如果他们仅仅根据你身上那个微小的方面来做出草率的判断，那是极其肤浅的，与你毫无关系。所以这有点像是一种平衡行为。把时间花在思考这上面，你放弃了什么；而把时间花在思考
something else, thinking about how you can give back, thinking about your goals, thinking about your dreams, thinking about other people and how you can make them happy, how you can make them feel loved. There's one more exercise that I really want to share when it comes to feeling a little bit weighed down by beauty standards, pretty privilege, all of that, and that is a self-love, self-gratitude checklist. list. This involves writing down 10 things that you love about yourself that have nothing to do with what you look like, whether that is your creativity, how thoughtful you are, that you're strong, kind, a good cook, a loving daughter, a loving sister. I think we have been conditioned into seeing ourselves only as other people see us, which is through the lens of obviously
其他事情上——思考你如何回馈社会、思考你的目标、思考你的梦想、思考其他人以及如何让他们快乐、如何让他们感到被爱——你又能收获什么。还有一个练习，当我为审美标准、外貌特权以及所有这些感到有些沉重时，我真的很想分享，那就是自爱与感恩清单。这包括写下10件你爱自己的事情，而这些事情与你的外表毫无关系，无论是你的创造力、你的体贴、你的坚强、善良、擅长烹饪、是一个充满爱心的女儿还是一个充满爱心的姐姐。我认为我们已经被潜移默化地认为自己只能通过别人看到我们的方式来认同自己，而这显然是通过
physical appearance. But when we actually break down that facade and really examine who we truly are if all of those things were taken away, we are able to get more in touch with the core of our true self and actually do something with that, do something valuable with all that time. I would also say what you consume is what you believe. So if you are constantly being exposed to only one type of individual on social media, on TikTok, on Instagram, you will course are going to have a very limited sample for what the average person truly looks like. It is one of the mechanisms by which beauty standards become indoctrinated and continue to control and influence us. Social media is very, very powerful. It is almost a way of learning what
外表的镜头。但当我们真正打破这层外表，如果把所有这些都拿掉，真正审视我们究竟是谁时，我们就能更好地接触到我们真正自我的核心，并用所有这些时间去做点什么，做一些有价值的事情。我还要说，你消费什么，你就会相信什么。因此，如果你在社交媒体、TikTok、Instagram上不断接触到某一种类型的人，你对普通人真正长相的样本量自然就会非常有限。这是审美标准被灌输并继续控制和影响我们的机制之一。社交媒体非常非常强大。它几乎成了一种通过你所接触到的内容来了解
society wants from you through the kind of content that you're exposed to. So I would really encourage you to diversify who you follow, really question why these. models and people look the way they do, how attainable that really is. What would you be giving up to be that person to look a certain way? And is it really worth it to just conform? Just so that people like you more, maybe. I'm starting to believe that it really isn't worth it, especially since when you try and fake being another person, someone that you're not, when you give up your very much individual unique beauty, you actually miss out on meeting people who are really, really, have just loved the real you, and I think that's such a shame. So one final disclaimer, I don't want
社会对你的期望的方式。所以我真的鼓励你们去丰富你们关注的对象，真正去质疑为什么这些模特和人会长成这样，这种状态到底有多大程度是可以达到的。为了成为那种人、为了看起来像某种样子，你会放弃什么？仅仅为了让别人更喜欢你，这样做真的值得吗？我开始觉得这真的很不值得，特别是当你试图假装成另一个人、一个不是你自己的人，当你放弃了你那非常独特的美时，你其实错过了遇见那些真正深深爱着真实的你的人的机会，我认为这太遗憾了。所以最后有一点声明，我不想
this to come off as like an admonishment of beauty, or seeing the need to take care of ourselves as a bad thing, or, you know, not sometimes benefiting from the confidence boost of looking really good and wearing makeup and having your nails done and your hair done. This is kind of by no means permission to criticize people who do experience pretty privilege or who are conventionally attractive. I think obviously empowerment comes in so many forms and some of that might come from changing our physical appearance. But I also think it's important to examine the societal influence that sometimes leaves us feeling obligated, that we need to meet conventional beauty standards in order to achieve some level of happiness or to be accepted or to be treated well.
这被当作是对美的谴责，或者把照顾好自己视为一件坏事，或者认为（你知道的）有时候从看起来很好、化了妆、做了美甲和美发所带来的自信提升中没有好处。这绝不是在批评那些确实体验到外貌特权或符合传统审美的人。我认为赋权显然有很多种形式，其中一些可能来自于改变我们的外表。但我也认为，审视社会影响力是很重要的，正是这种影响力有时让我们感到有义务去满足传统的审美标准，以便获得某种程度的幸福、被接纳或受到善待。
when we feel shame in that sense, shame for just being who we truly are, nothing good really comes from that. So you can still accept that beauty standards have a role in our lives and that there are certain things that maybe do align with the implementation of beauty standards that you enjoy. Like I said, getting your nails done or investing in a really nice outfit or following trends, that is still totally fine. As long as it doesn't feel like necessary, as long as it doesn't feel enforced. as long as it doesn't feel like if I don't do these things, my life will not be as good as I want
当我们在这个意义上感到羞耻时，为自己本来的样子感到羞耻时，真正的好结果是不会随之而来的。所以你依然可以接受审美标准在我们的生活中发挥作用，并且有些事情可能确实符合你所享受的审美标准的实施。就像我说的，做美甲、投资一套非常好看的衣服或追随潮流，这完全没问题。只要它不觉得是必要的，只要它不觉得是被强加的，只要它不觉得是“如果我不做这些事情，我的生活就会达不到我想要的
it to be. So I really hope that you've enjoyed this kind of more rambly episode. Honestly, it's just been something on my mind. I've just been really considering attractiveness recently, really been like looking at people on the street and being like, you're attractive, I can tell. Why is that? Why do I want to keep looking at you? Why do I keep looking at myself in the mirror. Why do I keep picking at my skin, picking it little things on my face or my body that I just don't quite like? Where does that come from? So I hope that this has been interesting, fascinating, enlightening that you have at least learnt something. And if you haven't learned something, I hope that it's just left you feeling a little bit better, a little bit more encouraged by the
程度”。所以我真的希望你们喜欢这期比较随性的节目。老实说，这只是我一直在思考的事情。我最近一直在认真思考吸引力，一直在观察街上的人，心想：你很有吸引力，我看得出来。这是为什么？为什么我一直想看你？为什么我一直照镜子？为什么我一直挑剔我的皮肤，挑剔我脸上或身上那些我不太喜欢的微小瑕疵？这源于哪里？所以我希望这期节目是有趣的、迷人的、启发的，至少能让你学到一些东西。如果你没有学到什么，我希望它能让你感觉好一点，多一点鼓励，因为
fact that you are not the only one who was thinking about beauty in maybe a dangerous, toxic way. I think it is very universal in our 20s, something that we should discuss more, something that we should be more open about, that this is not an isolated issue, all of us are consuming very similar content, feeling very similar things about what society expects from us in terms of looks. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. As always, if there is a friend who needs to hear this, please feel free to share it with them or leave a five-star review wherever you were listening. make sure you are following us so that you know when new episodes come out.
事实上，你并不是唯一一个以某种危险的、有毒的方式思考美的人。我认为这是我们在20多岁时非常普遍的心态，这是我们应该更多地讨论、更公开地探讨的事情，这不是一个孤立的问题，我们所有人都在消费非常相似的内容，对社会对我们外表的期望有着非常相似的感受。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。像往常一样，如果有朋友需要听这个，请随时分享给他们，或者在你收听的任何地方留下五星好评。请确保关注我们，以便了解新节目的发布时间。
And we are still taking episode suggestions. We're always taking episode suggestions. So if there's something that you want us to speak on, want us to look into, want us to understand the psychology of for you, please follow me at that psychology podcast and shoot me a message. And I'll chat to you over there. As always, have a lovely week. We will be back next week with another episode.
我们仍在接受节目建议。我们一直在接受节目建议。所以如果你有什么想让我们谈论的、想让我们深入研究的、想让我们为你解开心理谜团的事情，请在那个心理学播客关注我并给我发信息。我们在那里聊。像往常一样，祝大家度过美好的一周。我们下周会带着另一期节目回归。
2%. That's the number of people. who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、体能和培养复原力的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，
and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 That was a big moment for me
你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》播客，对于1979年来说，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。
84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense Of how we survived it
84对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的，
With our friends Fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s It was a wild I mean It was a wild year
和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔，聊聊80年代，那真是狂野的一段时光，我的意思是，那真的是狂野的一年，
I don't think There's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the Iheart radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the I-Hard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样做。在I-Hard radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《learn the hard way》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控
of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
生下了一对双胞胎，但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Alesspian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是真人。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。